die angst davor dass maschinen einmal
die macht ergreifen werden und uns alle
umbringen wollen gibt es schon seit
langer zeit doch mit apples siri ibm
watson und googles rain scheint diese
bedrohungen immer realer zu werden wie
wahrscheinlich ist der krieg zwischen
mensch und maschine kann es wirklich
sein dass künstliche intelligenz einmal
die menschheit auslöschen
herzlich willkommen zu einer weiteren
folge watson in vielen aktuellen filmen
wie zb wenn jazz age of alphorn oder ex
machina übrigens beides sehr gute filme
geht es um künstliche intelligenz das
schema ist die oft sehr typisch der
mensch kreiert künstliche intelligenz
die dann so intelligent wird dass die
lärm und sich selber verbessern kann
dann wird sie sehr schnell viel
intelligenter als es jemals ein mensch
sein könnte und lehnt sich gegen die
menschen auf
und ganz ehrlich ich finde es super dass
so viele filme über dieses thema gemacht
werden weil ich diese filme zum einen
sehr geil finde und zum anderen möchte
dass sich so viele menschen wie möglich
mit dem thema auseinandersetzen
aber die kehrseite ist dass viele
menschen diese böse ki die sich mit iron
man und hulk prügelt natürlich als
science fiction abstempeln nichts was es
wirklich geben könnte
aber genau das stimmt eben nicht schon
heute sind wir täglich von sogenannter
schwacher ki umgeben
ob sie spam mails filtert den aufzug im
haus positioniert oder euch vorschlägt
welches youtube-video ihr nach diesem
hier gucken sollte und algorithmen
übernehmen auch wichtigere aufgaben in
unserem leben wie zum beispiel das
schalten von ampelphasen oder das
handeln auf dem aktienmarkt klar diese
form von k s sind nur auf ihren
speziellen bereich programmiert und sie
würden schrecklich versagen wenn sie
auch nur leicht unterschiedliche
aufgaben bewältigen müssten
und trotzdem haben extrem viele experten
angst wenn es um die zukunft von
künstlicher intelligenz geht
stephen hawking meint dass die
entwicklung von genereller künstliche
intelligenz das ende der menschheit
bedeuten könnte ihnen masken für die
größte bedrohung unserer existenz und
bill gates stimmt ihm dabei zu und noch
hunderte weitere experten mit leider
weniger bekannten namen schließen sich
dem an
aber was ist so schlimm an künstlicher
intelligenz das problem ist dass wir
nicht wirklich wissen was passiert wenn
künstliche intelligenz einen punkt
erreicht an dem sie lernt und sich
selber verbessert dann wird sie dies mit
exponentiell an geschwindigkeit tun
also wird sie sich morgen viel schneller
verbessern als sie es gestern noch getan
hat vom äquivalent eines vierjährigen
kindes könnte es monate oder sogar jahre
dauern bis der computer das bewusstsein
eines normalen erwachsenen
doch sobald er die welt versteht wie du
und ich es tun ist es um ein vielfaches
einfacher sich weiterzuentwickeln und
noch mehr zu lernen
bis zum level eines einstein kann es
dann sehr schnell gehen und ehe man es
sich versieht ist der computer schlauer
als alle menschen zusammen
das bedeutet nicht dass eine ki die sich
selber verbessert und ein bewusstsein
entwickelt unbedingt schlecht sein muss
sie ist einfach nur so schnell so weit
über uns dass wir uns gar nicht
vorstellen können was im inneren vorgeht
so wie eine biene sich nicht mal im
ansatz vorstellen kann
welche gedanken ein mensch haben könnte
wir wären einer solchen intelligenz
schutzlos ausgeliefert
in einer welt in der intelligent sein
einen iq von 130 und dumm sein einen iq
von 85 bedeutet haben wir einfach kein
wort für einen iq von 12 1952 diese
könnte jede krankheit heilen oder eine
krankheit erschaffen die jeden menschen
auf diesem planeten innerhalb von
kürzester zeit tötet und es wäre für sie
so einfach wie wir ein toaster bedienen
aber wir können nicht wissen ob sie es
machen würde weil wir die ziele einer
solch hohen intelligenz einfach nicht
kennen und wahrscheinlich auch niemals
verstehen würden also was können wir tun
um das mögliche ende der menschheit zu
verhindern
als roboter gesetze sind bestimmt ein
guter ansatz
sie besagen dass roboter keinen menschen
verletzen dürfen uns gehorchen müssen
und sich selber am leben erhalten sollen
solange die ersten beiden regeln dabei
nicht gebrochen werden
manche forscher wollen zusätzlich noch
das den roboter an unsere menschlichen
gesetze und unsere werte und
moralvorstellungen eingebaut werden
wobei dies wahrscheinlich nur in form
von unzähligen weiteren regeln geschehen
könnte aber die bereits viele experten
angedeutet haben sind asiens roboter
gesetze nicht die perfekte lösung
selbst wenn die regeln so tief in den
algorithmen verankert sind dass die ki
sie nicht heraus schreiben könnte so
kann man die gesetze immer noch mehr
oder weniger frei auslegen künstliche
intelligenz hast dich nicht sie liebt
dich auch nicht aber du bist aus atomen
die sie auch für etwas anderes verwenden
kann
experten arbeiten erst seit kurzem an
der frage wie man ki unter kontrolle
halten kann und es könnte jahrzehnte
dauern bis sie zu einer antwort kommen
weil es eine extrem komplizierte und
vielschichtige frage ist wie
kontrolliert man etwas das um einiges
intelligenter ist
als man selbst und die frage gebe ich
jetzt einfach mal an euch weiter
schreibt mir eure meinung in die
kommentare ich bin wie immer sehr
gespannt was ihr zu sagen habt ansonsten
findet ihr hier rechts noch meine beiden
letzten folgen von law zorn oder ihr
lasst euch einfach von der youtube zu
einem mysteriösen anderen video führen
bis zum nächsten mal